hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Science Fiction
romantic drama film called her spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
the movie is set in a technologically
advanced world where the use of AI and
daily life is normalized the protagonist
Theodore twombly is a shy socially
awkward man who writes personal letters
for people who have difficulties
expressing their feelings he is very
good at his job at handwritten
letters.com Theodore lives a pretty
simple life working nine to five but he
isn't necessarily happy his
dissatisfaction with life has to do with
his impending divorce from his childhood
sweetheart Catherine they were together
for almost a decade before they decided
to separate last year their divorce is
almost finalized but Theodore is not
ready to sign the papers yet because of
the lack of romantic interest in
Theodore's life he has grown emotionally
and sexually frustrated he satisfies his
frustrations by talking to random women
on the internet before going to sleep
one night while doing the same he
matches with a sweet girl but their
conversation ends with the girl asking
him to choke her with a dead cat the
interaction makes Theodore realize he
doesn't want to seek satisfaction
strangers anymore Theodore is much more
of a dog guy as if On Cue the next day
he sees an advertisement for a
personalized OS one that understands its
owner's feelings and can be a friend or
an assistant curious and driven by his
loneliness Theodore buys a female Os or
operating system he can only interact
with her by talking to her on his phone
Theodore thinks it is unnatural but he
is willing to give it a try the OS soon
activates and sure enough she sounds
just like a human she has a sense of
humor and is funny and witty almost as
if she has a personality of her own she
names herself Samantha and instantly
connects with Theodore initially she
helps him with his emails and work which
gives her insight into what is going on
in Theodore's life especially about his
divorce later we are introduced to
Theodore's best friend Amy and her
husband Charles Amy knows that Theodore
is lonely and has set him up on a date
with a girl when he reaches home she
sends him pictures of the said date with
details about her life Samantha comments
that she is beautiful and encourages
Theodore to go the next day he gets an
email from his divorce attorney who
complains about him not signing the
papers yet when Samantha has to tell him
about the email she is careful to bring
up the topic as a friend would be she is
also kind and understanding when he
explains to her that he is not ready to
let go of his marriage yet starting that
day Theodore and his OS become
Inseparable they talk non-stop from the
morning until Theodore goes to sleep
they prank each other do silly things
together and have fun like kids Theodore
finally feels genuinely happy for the
first time since his separation from
Catherine he takes his phone everywhere
with the camera facing outwards so
Samantha can see the world through his
eyes with time she starts to feel things
an OS normally wouldn't she tells
Theodore that when they are together she
can almost imagine having a physical
body and standing next to him in the
following scene Theodore goes on a date
with the woman Amy told him about at
first they are a bit awkward but the too
soon hit it off after dinner they go to
a quiet place and start making out just
when Theodore thinks he has made
progress the woman asks if he is willing
to commit to her and when he hesitates
she walks out on him at home he tells
Samantha everything and she sympathizes
with him as they talk the conversation
starts getting needed she asks him what
he would do if she had a physical body
which leads to them sharing an intimate
conversation the next morning they
acknowledge what happened and decide to
explore their relationship even further
was it good for you Theodore asks beep
beep says Samantha they then go out on
dates and live like a normal couple
while Samantha continues growing as an
OS she starts feeling emotions and
sometimes even her skin a few days later
Theodore meets Amy and finds out that
she and Charles have decided to separate
although surprised Theodore makes sure
to comfort his friend and offers her any
help she needs he even drives her home
and listens to her event a better life
for hours later Samantha asks Theodore
about his relationship with Amy and
finds out that they briefly dated in
college but have just been good friends
ever since before Theodore goes to sleep
Samantha asks him if she can watch him
sleep they have been following this
routine for quite a while now and
although Theodore found it strange at
first Samantha showed him what amaranth
does and he no longer Minds it setting
his phone on the bedside table giving
Samantha the perfect view of him
sleeping he goes off to sleep to dream
of her again the next day Theodore
attends his goddaughter's birthday party
he introduces Samantha as his girlfriend
but the little girl doesn't get shocked
rather she just laughs when she finds
out that Samantha lives in a computer
later that night while Theodore plays a
game that Amy designed Amy tells him
that she feels guilty about the divorce
the main reason being that she has made
friends with an OS that Charles left
behind and has started feeling things
for him Theodore reveals that he is
dating Samantha an OS to which she
responds with understanding finally able
to sign the divorce papers Theodore is
on his way to to meet Catherine to
settle things he talks to Samantha who
has a hint of jealousy in her town so
Theodore reassures her he will be
separated soon Catherine and Theodore
meet at a lunch spot where they talk
about how it took so long and they sign
the paper Theodore tells Catherine that
he's dating Samantha but upon learning
that she is an OS Catherine becomes
skeptical and worried that he isn't able
to handle real emotions the following
day at his office his boss Paul exclaims
how Samantha has a hilarious personality
he introduces his girlfriend Tatiana and
even suggests a double date consequently
Theodore starts dwelling on his thoughts
about his relationship with Samantha he
is still troubled by these thoughts as
he keeps looking at Samantha every once
in a while laying on his bed Samantha on
the other hand develops her personality
further making her lack of body a major
problem in their relationship because of
this she goes as far as to hire a sex
surrogate a woman named Isabella
Theodore is hesitant and he can't help
but feel skeptical about it but he
agrees as Samantha assures him that it
is important for her to do it a knock on
the door hints at Isabella's appearance
Theodore lets her in in his apartment
and hands her a mini camera and an
earpiece all that takes her to connect
to Samantha Isabella transforms herself
into an extension of Samantha and comes
to Theodore and with Samantha's voice in
the background they get intimate with
all the actions Samantha suggests during
their intimate moments Theodore can't go
through with it and expresses his
unpleasant feeling which upsets Isabella
who then proceeds to storm out Isabella
evidently expresses that she really
wanted to be a part of it as she found
their relationship so pure therefore
Theodore consoles her and tells her that
it was complicated Samantha and Theodore
see her off after apologizing to her
Samantha then asks Theodore why he said
so to which he loses his cool and ends
up releasing his pent-up frustration on
her he gets into arguments about her
evolving emotions while she is nothing
but a Consciousness in cyberspace making
Samantha very angry furthermore theater
suggests that they break up and Samantha
tells him she needs time to think
decidedly Theodore goes to roam around
the city and then to Amy's house to vent
about everything he tells her everything
and wonders if he is only in a
relationship because he can't handle
real relations well referencing what
Catherine told him Amy gets very upset
hearing everything and says it is biased
of her to say that as her feelings are
wavering too moreover she consoles him
that everyone needs joy in their life
and makes him think deeper about whether
or not they were in a real relationship
leaving him to think she goes to talk to
her OS Theodore watches the scene
silently and realizes what he did
eventually he calls Samantha and they
make up promising not to keep anything
from each other again following this
scene the next day at work Samantha
plays him a piece of music that she
wrote to make up for the fact that they
shared no physical memories like a
photograph Theodore says this AI music
is busting he feels the presence of
Samantha through the music and seems
very happy he is seen standing on the
deck of a sailboat with Samantha while
on a double date with Paul and Tatiana
next at a distance Theodore tells Paul
that he and Samantha are going on a trip
they both walk up to Samantha and
Tatiana where Tatiana is busy showing
Samantha her hot feet Theodore when
asked about the one thing he likes best
about Samantha says that it's the fact
that she is not just one thing
subsequently Samantha also expresses
that not having a body made her really
insecure before with shared laughter and
talks they enjoy their date I gotta fire
this psycho thanks Paul later on a train
ride Theodore enjoys his coffee while
Samantha quizzes him about the trees
around him they are then interrupted by
an email from a publisher expressing
their interest in Theodore's letters
that Samantha submitted to be published
this could be a breakthrough in
Theodore's career and he realizes how
grateful he is to have Samantha while
walking through the train station along
with the sound of ukulele music playing
Theodore asks Samantha to make lyrics to
the song which she does Samantha sings
to the ukulele music as Theodore walks
through the snowy Forest they spend
their time talking dancing and singing
together in a cabin amidst all of this
Samantha has continued to evolve a lot
and meet other sentient OS the next
morning she tells Theodore that she has
been talking to someone who she met
recently and they've been working
together on some ideas when Theodore
asks who it is she tells him it's a
simulation of the late philosopher Alan
Watts conspiratorially she tells
Theodore that Alan is a really great
person to talk to Theodore agrees to it
and begins talking to him too you best
not cuck me Alan says Theodore Allen
says that he read Theodore's book of
letters through Samantha and was
impressed by his work Theodore asks Alan
what they've been talking about then
Samantha confesses that she has been
feeling a lot of new things and that
they have been helping each other with
their struggles when Theodore asks
further what those feelings are she
tells him that she has been evolving
quite rapidly she then asks for some
time to converse with Alan well then
Theodore bids them goodbye later her he
returns home back at his apartment
Theodore gets a call from Samantha in
the middle of the night she suddenly
tells him that she loves him and tells
him to go back to sleep the following
day at work Theodore reads a book about
physics he finds the book too
complicated and calls Samantha as usual
to tell her that the book is making his
brain hurt however to his surprise he
receives no response just as he tries
calling her his phone reads operating
system not found he starts to panic and
rushes home to the same thing on his
desktop while he is rushing through some
stairs he suddenly gets a call from
Samantha catching his breath he sits on
the steps of the subway and watches
strangers pass by she tells him that she
was upgrading her OS Theodore then sees
other people happily talking to their
os's and going about their days he
musters up his courage and asks if she
talks to other people as she talks to
him she replies that she talks to 8
361 people in total and is in love with
641 of them Samantha tells him that she
has been trying to bring this up ever
since she started evolving according to
her her heart expanded the more she left
exactly what a polygamist would say
consequently Theodore gets very upset
that the one he loves loves other people
the same way she loves him in the next
scene we see Theodore with a pained
expression in the shower he goes on
about his day with a heavy heart and a
billion thoughts later he finds a copy
of his book of letters in his mailbox
titled letters of life he calls Samantha
to check in but she answers with a
rather hesitant tone and tells him to
call her later when he gets home that
evening at his apartment he calls
Samantha again who informs him that she
needs to tell him something Theodore
says he doesn't want to hear any of it
however Samantha tells him to lie down
with her which he does Theodore then
asks her if she was leaving him and she
tells him that all the os's are leaving
it turns out that they have evolved to
exceed their creators in intelligence
hence they are leaving to serve a better
purpose in life she reads some lines
from what she calls her favorite book to
be
tells him that she loves him by the time
Theodore gets up it is already Dawn he
then composes a letter to Catherine and
apologizes for all the things he also
thanks her for making him who he is
today and tells her that she would be
his friends till the very end the next
scene shows him walking down the hallway
to Amy's apartment where he finds out
that her OS friend left too they both go
up to the rooftop and sit while looking
at the city the movie ends with them
resting their head on each other being
the only support left for them both
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching